[Music]
tell us who you flew next to in 2015
2015 here's my year it starts off with
Bruce Bruce the comedian he's a great
comic yeah okay right this is Bruce
McAdams here sir
Serena Williams greatest famous female
tennis player vaulter then Chris Tucker
and then former heavyweight champion of
the world Iron Mike Tyson so you're on a
plane and they're like either on the
seat next to or across the aisle easily
who ever did you ever talk to any of
them I talked to all of them and every
conversation was unique Chris Tucker he
landed off of a spaceship and then got
on our flight but then Tyson was the
most just bananas because he's Mike
Tyson and I got to watch people watch
him which was crazy you know because
people would flip out when they saw him
yeah they got this people look alike and
I kind of freaked out and he was nice to
people it's a it's like a late afternoon
flight to Pittsburgh from LA and I go
I'm not gonna bother the guy and then
after a while I decided you know what I
am gonna bother this guy you know okay
I'm never gonna run into him yeah so I
walk over to his seat and I go I'm sorry
to bother you I grew up watching all
your fights and I'm a big fan yeah he
was like thank you it's a decent I don't
pretty good good enough yeah
really good thank you yeah so I said I'm
just curious why are you why are you
going to Pittsburgh and he goes I'm
promoting a fight what about you and I
said I'm a comedian I'm going to do
shows and at that moment everything
switched like he just goes like you're
comedians there you go yeah and he goes
where's your show and I said it's a
comedy club it's called the Pittsburgh
improv and he goes way as that I have
absolutely no idea and he goes oh is
your show tonight and I go now like it's
11 o'clock at night and on a plane
[Laughter]
run the sky right now where they sky he
goes he goes well when's your show and I
go tomorrow and he goes where and I
still at the Pittsburgh anyway and he's
like how do I find it and like do I
don't know google it you know you told
Mike Tyson yeah yeah like Google a
that's exactly how it's you know you say
something and in a two seconds later
you're like that definitely should not
have said that because I feel like I
feel like I have Mike Tyson asking me
where's your show and I'm like figure it
out so as soon as I say that I'm like
you idiot so I grab a DVD out of my bag
and I give it to him and I go look at my
name on it so you have to remember my
name type that in and you can you can
see see well yeah yeah and he goes thank
you
I go that's cool I met Tyson I sit back
in my seat ten seconds later I hear Tom
right and I like yes Mike Tyson yeah and
he goes I've been watching a lot of
Netflix that's it that's all he said
and I never thought that sentence could
be terrifying to hear from somebody
right
I'm just looking at I'm like yeah okay
sure
and he goes no I recognize you and I'm
like what and he holds up the DVD and I
got now dude like I I just gave that
and he goes now it's the same picture
that's on Netflix
Wow and I go yeah it's the same picture
he goes I know who you are I go that's
crazy and he goes give me your phone
number I'm like what I give him my
number
wheel and I sprint off the plane it's
like too much weirdness for one day sure
concentrated yeah it's it the next day
I'm sitting in my hotel room and I get a
text message from Mike Tyson and know
what it said what waves you show can he
show up he did he can't actually brought
a picture here there
[Applause]